[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux pour
tous et pour ceux 7,8 sport le magazine
est consacrée comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire football
trappage de son premier match de l'année
2018 à domicile après avoir fermé son
terrain pendant deux mois suite aux
intempéries
pour leur retour dans leur stade les
trappistes ont fait match nul 1 but
partout contre plutôt le résumé du match
et a su dans quelques instants
foot us les templiers à d'elancourt
jouer leur troisième match de la saison
contre les pionniers de touraine
désolant courtois se sont imposés à 21,6
avec leur nouvelle un porc américain
plus de détails dans ce magazine
cyclisme la 76e édition du paris-nice
partira depuis les yvelines ce dimanche
4 mars
la première étape est programmée entre
chatouille la ville de meudon en passant
par le centre du département
la seconde phase sera par la petite
commune d'orson bil'in village de 400
habitants
zoom sur la compétition coup de
projecteur à présent sur les principaux
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
football ont joué ce week end et match
en retard du championnat de r4 trap a
enfin rejoué dans son stade après avoir
vu une trêve forcée pendant deux mois
suite aux intempéries
pour son retour à la compétition à
domicile les trappistes ont pu faire
mieux que match nul 1 but partout contre
plutôt des images signées à nicolas
landry un but qui fait mal jusqu'à cette
fameuse 85e minute les verts de trappes
mené 1-0 contre plutôt en match en
retard du championnat de régionale 4 un
avantage acquis rapidement sur la
première action du match suite cette
récupération les trappistes ont ensuite
reculé en seconde période avant de se
faire égaliser
on s'y attendait pas on a ouvert le
score très tôt après c'est très
difficile de savoir gérer un
une ouverture de score très rapidement
comme ça on l'a plutôt bien fait
malheureusement sur les dix dernières
minutes on traque parce qu'on a trop
vouloir chercher ce deuxième onze
reprises l'égalisation dans cette
rencontre et n'a pas réussi à se mettre
à l'abri rapidement malgré deux
occasions nettes en première période
un manque de réalisme récurrent pour
cette équipe qui n'a marqué que 18 buts
en 14 matches de championnat aura manqué
d'adressé le but c'est effectivement
et puis au delà la cathédrale manqué de
finition est vraiment faite sur la fin
quoi d'un geste n'a pas été bien
l'appliquer comme ça arrive sur
plusieurs joueurs différents donc la
première fois le premier joueur il doute
la deuxième fois le deuxième joueur
doutera la troisième fois le troisième
joueur doutera et ainsi de suite et et
sa patronne lui notre secteur offensif
en confiance qu'ils ont dans la foulée
on
on va pas se chercher des excuses il ya
des jours où justement on va pas du tout
marquer on a eu la chance d'en mettre un
malheureusement on n'a pas été ce
costaud pour préserver ce score là un
manque de réalisme qu'il faudra corriger
dès ce dimanche 4 mars en match en
retard contre goussainville
avant cette rencontre à pointe à la 11e
place du championnat à notre résultat de
football mais cette fois ci dans le
championnat de national troyes
versailles se déplaçait ce samedi sur le
terrain de saint-ouen l'aumône et les
versets ils se sont imposés par la plus
petite des marges 1 à 0 un résultat qui
leur permet de grimper à la 2e place du
championnat avec un point d'avancé sur
aubervilliers
prochain match pour versailles samedi
prochain à domicile contre le leader à
bobigny la rencontre est programmée à
18h on ouvre maintenant une page
handball trappe s'est incliné à 24 à 19
ce dimanche contre bondoufle en 16e de
finale de la coupe de france
départementale et sort de la compétition
un beau parcours pour ce club qui sert
créé en 2014 pour nous parler de cette
rencontre nous recevons sur ce plateau
l'entraîneur frédéric bélanger imad
issouf aig et le gardien de but et le
joueur théo guichou bonsoir alors soir
il était vraiment plus fort que vous sur
cette rencontre monde où je vais
commencer à tout d'abord dont 12 qui
joue une division au dessus de nous on
était prêt pour ce match on a perdu 2,5
buts malheureusement
personnellement je pense qu'on a loupé
les occasions à des moments cruciaux du
match
et par la suite ça n'a pas pardonné on
sait on s'est fait punir
on a deux gros regret je pense pas
qu'ils étaient plus forts que nous pour
répondre à la question
voilà on a manqué d'efficacité et
peut-être peut-être de rigueur je pense
que le coach fred pourra peut-être en
dire plus d'un avis extérieur mais ouais
on a deux sentiments qui sont partagés
en le premier c'est la fierté on va dire
d'être arrivé jusque là parce que c'est
un beau parcours c'est on ne s'attendait
pas à ça en début d'année on visait le
championnat puisque c'est l'objectif
c'est la montée
et puis ce parcours-là est arrivé tour
après tout on a passé un tour un
deuxième un taureau penalty un tour
gagné la dernière minute donc petit à
petit on se prend au jeu et puis jusqu'à
se dire c'est la finale à bercy donc
c'est quelque chose qu'on les tours
passent dans arriver donc en 16e de
finale 8e et filage il a versé
ça commençait en fait c'est on va dire
que c'est au début on s'imagine pas
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de tours là
c'était cinq tours pour arriver rien
qu'en 16e donc ça fait beaucoup de tours
mais une fois qu'on y est on se dit bon
ben voilà on pourrait peut-être
commencer à y penser et puis là ça
s'arrête
et c'est là où on est un petit peu un
petit peu frustré donc il ya la fierté
du parcours parce qu'on avait réussi
pour ce pour l'occasion à grâce à la
lettre de la mairie a mobilisé près de
soixante soixante spectateurs qui
s'étaient déplacés donc
9h30 le matin dimanche matin pendant les
vacances à l'autre bout de l'île de
france parce qu'entre trappe et livry
gargan ça faisait une première pour le
club
ah oui complètement déjà arrivé arriver
à ce stade de la compétition
et puis donc de ce côté à fierté du
parcours fierté d'avoir porté l'espoir
et puis d'avoir été portés par cet
espoir des supporters et la déception de
perdre face à une équipe en effet qui
était qu'à fait son match
clairement pas ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont fait un bon match mais nous l
inverse
trop de choses on manquait donc on est
on est un peu déçu parce qu'on n'a pas
vraiment défendu nos chances à fond pour
son a l'impression de pas avoir défendu
imad qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
sur cette rencontre je pense déjà ses
matches avait trop fait la fête
non mais j'ai trop supporter l'équipe
dimanche du coup j'ai plus de voix mais
oui je pensais peut-être le match à 9h30
le matin comme ça mais bon c'est un peu
un parcours on n'y croyait pas trop et
peut-être d'y être ça ça nous a surpris
un peu mais en tout cas on était prêt et
on a tous notre côté on s'est bien
entraîné on avait bien préparé le match
ça s'est joué pour moi ça s'est joué à
rien du tout séjour rien du tout mais je
pense que si on a si ça arriverait si ça
arrive qu'on rejoue contrebande ou je
pense que la victoire serait quasiment
assuré je pense théo malgré ce résultat
le coach le disait ce parcours restera
gravé dans l'histoire du club
on peut le dire oui tout à fait c'est
vrai que déjà c'est une première c'était
une première et ensuite on tient à
remercier tous les supporters parce que
c'est notre plus grande victoire c'est
vrai qu'on remercie la mairie trappe et
notamment à lire à b l'adjoint au maire
des sports et de la jeunesse qui ont
affrété gratuitement un bus nous que de
64 personnes me créer une ire 64
personnes pour un match à 9h30 c'est
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire
sans compter les personnes qui se sont
déplacées par leurs propres moyens
donc ça a été une belle fête
un bel événement qui restera gravé en
nous et puis voilà c'est une défaite qui
va permettre nous permet de nous de nous
construire de nous forger et on espère
une prochaine pas c'est le cas il ya eu
également cette belle victoire 34 à 25
en janvier dernier contre argenteuil
c'était vraiment souvenir inoubliable ce
match ça restera peut-être le plus beau
souvenir de cette compétition oui parce
que c'est la coupe c'est un charme
particulier dans l'est une centaine de
supporters lors d'une
on a on a la chance aussi d'avoir un
d'avoir un public un engouement un
argument un engouement populaire
derrière le club
donc c'est vrai que les matches à
domicile sont souvent tous les jeunes du
club viennent les amis donc vraiment il
ya un engouement
beaucoup d'équipés redoute un petit peu
j'ai un trac parce que savent que le
public se manifestent beaucoup donc on a
ce soutien là mais là pour le coup vu
que ça représente et on était le dernier
représentant du 78 donc ça c'était
important et donc du coup beaucoup de
gens savaient attiré ça va attirer des
gens extérieurs qui étaient venus voir
un petit peu ce qu'était comme on joue
et rap
et puis donc en effet d'une émotion on a
passé un tour au penalty aux tirs au but
un tour en gagnant à la dernière minute
donc là on a gagné un petit peu plus
largement donc c'était pas dire c'était
un petit peu plus ceux moins tendu parce
que d'habitude on est on a souvent à
dernière minute but donc c'est quand
même plus tendue d'habitude il m'a dit
vous pensez que ça peut attirer d
débutant à venir tester le handball à
trappes
bah ça commence déjà même pas mal de
jeunes qui viennent
qui sont ces performances la suite ah
ouais c'est un peu à tout général peu à
l'ambiance comment ça se passe dans les
matches si comme on gagne aussi nos
victoires parfois qu'ils sont vraiment
qu'ils jouent vraiment jusqu'à la
dernière seconde
aussi c'est aussi un peu un exemple
aussi pour les jeunes où on peut leur
dire que vraiment toujours jusqu'au bout
quoi
et des fois ça les intéresse ils voient
comment joue comment comment vraiment
c'est cet esprit d'équipé
si cette ambiance qui est unique aussi
attrape un moment on retrouve pas on
retrouve pas c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est propre à chez nous même
malgré que il ya plusieurs années on
avait fermé
on a ouvert il ya quatre ans et pourtant
si resté exactement la même chose ça va
pas changer
théo trap est d'ordinaire plus primée
pour son football
là c'est pour du handball est ce que
vous pensez qu'un jour leurs balles pour
arriver au niveau du football le
football c'est peut-être compliqué mais
c'est vrai que l'objectif maintenant
c'est de fédérer nos supporters autour
d'un projet commun et bien entendu aussi
de communiqué que ce soit sur les
réseaux sociaux ou par différents médias
comme comme vous qui permet de donner de
la visibilité sur le club de trappes et
pour en revenir au match de coupe de
france face à argenteuil
on a vraiment décidé de développer notre
communication
voilà et c'est vrai que le stade était
vraiment rempli sa permis de nous fait
nous faire connaître pardon des
personnes qui ne connaissaient pas le
club auparavant qui ont découvert le
club de trappes
grâce à ce match et qui dorénavant nous
suivent
nous suivre de près lors de nos matches
et de nos déplacements donc c'est une
bonne chose pour le club et la ville de
trappes
merci à tous les trois d'être passé sur
son plateau bonne continuation pour la
fin du championnat et bientôt sur le
plateau de tv 78 une fois que peut-être
vous remporterez peut-être un jour cette
cette coupe de france
merci beaucoup en tout cas nous allons
maintenant parler de football américain
un petit nouveau est arrivé chez les
templiers à d'elancourt son nom qui se
révoltent ce ne vous fiez pas à son
patronyme hollywoodien 7 un porc
américain de 26 ans originaire du mythe
du mississippi a joué au niveau
universitaire au canada et dans l'équipe
des green bay bizarre où il a été l'un
des meilleurs défenseurs de l'équipe
il explique les raisons qui l'ont poussé
à traverser l'atlantique au micro de
nicolas d'henry j'ai eu une super
opportunité de venir ici le coach m'a
donné cette chance d'aider cette équipe
à gagner et je vais essayer de le faire
je vais apporter mon expérience sur le
terrain et aussi aider les jeunes à
progresser dans le vrai football
américain tout juste arrivée qui se
rénove s'était aligné chez les templiers
à del en cours il a pu participer à la
première victoire à domicile de la
saison des élans courtois dans le
championnat de deuxième division les
yvelinois se sont imposés 21 à 6 face
aux pionniers de touraine sous des
températures à glacial le résumé du
match
avantage de jules grenier ville du
sérieux et de la détermination
deux ingrédients qui ont permis aux
templiers d'elancourt de tenir leur rang
contre les pionniers de touraine lors de
la 4e journée du championnat de 2e
division
score final 21 6 première victoire de la
saison à domicile
donc en gros jeu au sol c'est ça qui
nous a permis de tenir le match entre
guillemets on prend pas beaucoup de
yards en défense donc on est pas mal là
dessus il faut qu'on s'améliore un peu
sur le jeu à la passe et puis qu'on soit
plus efficace soit même distance à voir
tout ce qu'ils ont fait on l'avait vu à
la vidéo sur leurs deux premiers matches
et a rien que nous a vraiment surpris
à la fin du match il n'avait plus
vraiment de réponse à face à notre
attaque donc ils mettaient beaucoup de
pression on a réussi à inscrire quête de
trois brèches pour sombrer essence ce
populaire dedans et ça a bien marché
pour nous seul bémol de ce match
référence ce touch donne encaissé en fin
de match par les templiers d'elancourt
sous une température de l'air
elle une séquence de jeu qui a eu
tendance à agacer le staff de l'équipe
quand le match se passe bien on a
tendance à se relâcher et c'est vrai que
si on met par la glande sur la touche on
a vite fait de se disperser et c'est
vrai que faut que les gars se rappelle
que même si on est devant c'est
important il faut exécuter jusqu'au coup
de sifflet parce qu'on sait jamais ce
qui peut se passer
on a vécu trop de match catastrophe qui
sont retournés en deux minutes et on se
retrouve le bec dans l'eau à la fin du
match donc pourrait pas que ça se
reproduise au classement les tons pied
toujours invaincu reste deuxième de la
poule 2 ils sont toujours en course pour
les playoffs de fin de saison
prochain match le samedi 4 mars sur le
terrain des corsaires d'evry on passe
maintenant à notre sport de contact le
rugby plaisir jouer ce 18 février l'un
de ses matches les plus importants de sa
saison dans le championnat de fédérale 2
contre arras les deux équipes sont
toutes les deux en course dans la lutte
pour le maintien et les plaisirs wallon
emporté 23 17 à l'extérieur et bouffée
d'oxygène au classement plaisir est aux
portes de la zone de relégation à la 10e
place sur douze engagés et compte
désormais neuf points d'avancé sur le
premier relégable
arras son adversaire du jour autant dire
que le maintien est presque acquis pour
le premier on écoute l'entraîneur
sébastien roncalli sportivement et de
par le travail effectué par les joueurs
et tout le staff et les dirigeants voilà
je pense que c'est tout à fait mérité
c'était vraiment très important
prépare vraiment des choses on s'est
projeté sur plusieurs années donc ouais
c'était vraiment important de se
maintenir cette saison les joueurs sont
très très contents ils ont fait un
week-end très très sérieux puisque on
était quand même partis la veille donc
on avait bien préparé
d'ailleurs je les félicite ou mais
seniors que ce soit la une et la baie
voilà ils ont été vraiment un très
professionnelle sur le week-end est très
sérieux un grand bravo encore une
nouvelle fois pour l'équipe de plaisir
pour ce résultat les plaisirs hu a
justement eu la chance de ne pas jouer
ce week end vu la vague de froid qui
traverse en ce moment à l'île de france
pour la première fois depuis à mars 2005
la région enregistrent des températures
négatives et des ressentis pouvant aller
jusqu'à -10° un facteur avec lequel les
joueurs ont dû composer à ce week-end
sur les terrains pour ne pas se blesser
et surtout pour emporter à la victoire
des images de nicolas d'andré il essaye
de se réchauffer comme ils le peuvent
alors que ce soir là le thermomètre
affiche trois petits degrés les joueurs
de football américain des templiers
d'elancourt utilise un chauffage
électrique en extérieur sur le bord du
terrain
forcément le froid alors malema qui
frise et pour attraper de balancer un
petit peu moins facile mais ça fait
partie du jeu ça se contrôle pas donc il
faut faire avec cet objectif éviter les
blessures au niveau des mains comme il
fait prendre les ballons sont durs donc
c'est vrai qu'au niveau des doigts ça ça
limite la casse parce que dans la vie de
fait sauter une articulation par contre
davantage du froid c'est que on a mal en
ce sens - le staff a également
provisionné chaufferont pendant la mi
temps pour éviter cette fois ci les
pépins musculaires en est revenue un peu
plus tôt sur le terrain pour voir le
temps de faire un bon échauffement pour
être sûr d'être prêt à repartir et
remettre les gars de dents est vrai que
sur le premier drive en attaque ils ont
eu du mal à se remettre dedans mais une
fois qu'ils sont réchauffées après deux
trois coups de casque
c'était reparti le lendemain les
températures tombent à moins de 3 degrés
en plein après midi sur le stade de
gilbert chant sac de trappes pour
combattre le froid les joueurs ont
élaboré des stratégies
un cycliste en dessous la crème mezzo
pas nous qui colle au corps en morceaux
et on n'a pas trop changement également
dans la préparation d'avant match les
joueurs sortent au dernier moment pour
s'échauffer
pas de coupure programme jusqu'au début
de la partie pendant que le corse après
l'effort donc du coup faut que les
semences à saint plancard éviter le
point que le corps monte en température
il s'apprête pas à l'effort le froid des
conditions de jeu compliqué pour le
poste de gardien de but
immobile une grande partie du match
mamadou magassa doit composer avec ce
facteur
il faudrait toujours parler ça ça permet
de garder garder vraiment l'esprit à
chaud en cas de dominos de notre part il
faudrait que je rêve toujours mobile
c'est à dire faire des petits mouvements
pour pas pour pas choper un coup de
frein le week-end prochain les
températures devraient remonter sur les
terrains dix degrés sont attendues pour
ce week end pour le plus grand bonheur
des joueurs
on passe maintenant à l'agenda du
week-end
[Musique]
du cyclisme pour débuter cet agenda la
76e édition du paris-nice s'élancera
pour la neuvième année consécutive
depuis les yvelines après bois d'arcy en
2017 c'est au tour de chatou d'être
ville départ le 4 mars le peloton
s'élancera pour un départ fictif de
ligne des impressionnistes avant un
départ réel à four que et cyclistes
passeront ensuite par ville projet
villiers saint frédéric avant de
s'engouffrer dans la vallée de chevreuse
le lendemain les sportifs partiront du
petit village d'orson ville pour lui
parler de ce paris nice 2018 deux
personnalités du cyclisme local jean
michel richefort vice-président à la
effet ses membres du club de vélizy 78
et thierry fabre le président du
vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir alors
avant de revenir sur le tracé de 135km
nous allons écouter les réactions des
organisateurs sur ce tracé évinois on va
les chercher à coups de boules et les
trous on va aller chercher la coupe de
châteaufort mais côté stèle jacques
anquetil donc ça parle aussi ses démos
cds sont des endroits qui parle et un
retour sur saint quentin en yvelines
bois d'arcy et après on sûr du
département à la celle saint cloud là on
a fait en sorte de bad met pas mal de
portions à découvert de n'être pas mal
de difficultés ce que le département des
yvelines nous permet de faire sur paris
nice c'est justement de varier suivant
les lieux de départ puisque c'est
maintenant la 9e année une fois c'est un
contre-la-montre une fois c'est une
étape en circuit là pour la première
fois ça va être une arrivée en bosse
donc c'est une arrivée très intéressante
et là encore pour des puncheurs et dans
les puncheurs y ait encore des français
précisément à l'ats philippe tony
gallopin il ya aussi et dan martin
l'irlandais mais comme paris nice se
joue à quelques secondes près les
secondes qui seront prises ou perdu dès
le premier dimanche dans les ive et
compteront sans aucun depuis jours après
sur la promenade des anglais
jean michel richefort que pensez-vous du
tracé et bien c'est une très belle
première étape de 235 km
au coeur de la vallée heureuse avec les
codes des dix sept tournant bien sur la
côte de château fort mais ça ne fait pas
la sélection parce que les coureurs l'un
des 22 équipes sont prêts à en découdre
c'est quand même l'une des premiers et
des premières grandes épreuves de
l'année
et moi je retiens surtout le final ce
final pour monter à l'observatoire de
meudon avec une montée qui va faire deux
kilomètres va être réservé aux puncheurs
et on risque d'avoir du spectacle
effectivement un final qui va convenir à
l'ats philippe alaphilippe qui est un
puncheur mais aussi arnaud demare sera
pas loin je pense aux français déjà pas
de contre la montre
thierry fabre mais une vraie première
étape 1 ouvrez première étape va être je
pense difficile personne ne s'y attend
mais on a quand même une région qui est
me connais bien et jean-michel on
s'entraîne sur soc dans cette veine
chevreuse et casse-pattes donc il faut
se méfier et du vent en sortant deux des
dix sept tournant face au vent attention
la bordure qui s'accélère donc ça peut
jouer ça peut jouer à quelques secondes
mais il peut y avoir quelques paquets je
pense que la première était pouvait y
avoir quelques surprises
on peut vraiment attaqué sur ce tracé ça
va se faire je pense que ça sert plutôt
en équipe donc
les leaders vont être protégé il ya
quelques coups qui vont partir est ce
que les équipes vont maintenir la
pression sur les coûts qu'ils partent
je pense que c'est une étape surprise et
comme lui et jean-michel l'arrivée c'est
pour les costauds jean michel vous êtes
aussi d'accord avec neary je suis de son
équipe finalement ce cette première
étape de thierry parce que la vallée de
chevreuse réserve toujours des surprises
il y à des pièges
effectivement après c'est une course de
placement je pense peut-être une course
de mouvement mais c'est très court c'est
très court donc ça risque d'être nerveux
et bien sûr tout le monde veut être
présent et tout le monde veut s'imposer
dès la première étape alors je pense
qu'on va avoir du spectacle les
organisateurs en tout cas de leur côté
ont imaginé ce parcours pour rendre la
course aussi magique que l'année
dernière avec une victoire au bout de
l'effort à bois d'arcy dans les
conditions dantesques on écoute ce
christian prudhomme c'était une erreur
absolument magnifique alors c'était dur
aussi aux conditions atmosphériques bien
sûr c'était une étape folle la pluie le
vent les bordures et savait donner une
étape est insolente qui s'était terminé
par un doublé français la lecture
d'arnaud démare devant julian
alaphilippe donc c'était c'était plutôt
pas mal
si allez vous pensez qu'il peut y avoir
autant de spectacles que l'année
dernière à bois d'arcy
ça dépendra de la météo je pense qu'ils
annoncent déjà un peu de pluie pour
dimanche sont les derniers de la
dernière levée avec un peu de vent donc
oui ça va être ça va être difficile
ça va être difficile la météo c'est un
facteur important comme julie snyder
étape casse pattes quand on voit le
profil général de ceux de ce paris-nice
je pense que cette année si on faire si
on se projette un peu sur toutes les
étapes je pense que cette année il rappe
attendait ira beaucoup plus d'écart que
d'habitude parce que y'a qu'un contrôle
un monde comme à saint-etienne
l'arrivée à veulent d'abord en montagne
je pense que cette année dira je paie
j'espère qu'en france il sera dehors
jean michel vous pensez qu'un français
peut remporter cette première étape dans
les yvelines
c'est possible oui bien sûr parce que il
ya un très bonne année nacer bouhanni
des tony gallopin des julian alaphilippe
moi il ne faut pas oublier tony gallopin
qui est en pleine forme julian
alaphilippe bien sûr mais quelqu'un
aussi enquis moi je miserais c'est
lilian calmejane calmejane qui est
vraiment un des grands espoirs du
cyclisme français qui est en forme il
l'a déjà prouvé cette année
et puis c'est le genre d'épreuve qui va
lui convenir parce que c'est un coureur
complet c'est un rouleur c'est un
grimpeur
il va bien contre la montre et je pense
que
il saura sans aucun doute parmi les
favoris donc pas forcément français
chevronnés comme bois nippon où tony
gallopin non boigny c'est plus sûr des
arrivées au sprint si tony gallopin
c'est une valeur sûre
tony est toujours présente toujours
classé bon et cette année avec de
nouvelles nouveau rôle dans sa nouvelle
équipe
je pense qu'il sera là bien sûr donc bon
faut pas oublier il y a six équipes
françaises est parmi les 22 équipes au
départ donc beaucoup de français
beaucoup de bons français il ya un très
bon niveau chez les français donc on
peut miser
on peut miser sur français est aussi le
petit village d'orson ville qui a été
retenu pour cette deuxième étape un
village de 400 habitants l'écoutent la
réaction du nouvel ambassadeur du paris
nice 2018 lançant chouchou du public
thomas voeckler moi je trouve ça bien
parce que le vélo c'est pas que le tour
de france des épreuves comme paris nice
ça permet aussi à des communes qui n'ont
peut-être pas toujours les moyens
d'accueillir le tour de france abat
d'avoir une épreuve cycliste de renom
avec des coureurs de renom et et puis
bien faire plaisir à tout le monde aux
habitants aux gamins des écoles pas loin
en quoi c'est bien thierry or sont ville
c'est une super histoire pour ce petit
village
oui ça va mettre 400 habitants je le
disais sur dans quelques heures la
capitale du cyclisme c'est merveilleux
pour un petit village de 400 de 400
personnes la mairesse m'en parlait la
semaine dernière c'est un honneur et on
va découvrir un village yves dinoire
qu'on n'entend jamais parler et c'est
vrai qu'il a raison thomas voeckler il
ya des cyclistes qui vont se reconnaître
dans ce petit village des habitants qui
vont regarder la télévision se faire
plaisir en or sont ville super on voit
mon village on voit ma région je pense
que l'idée de de promouvoir paris nice
dans notre département déjà sérieusement
puisse faire connaître des petits
villages comme il ya quelques années
qu'on dise qu'on dit sur vègre ça a été
une réussite à condé mais si j'en parle
encore c'est très très bien merci à tous
les deux est passé sur ce plateau je
vous souhaite un bon paris-nice de
l'autre côté on fera un débriefing de
ces deux étapes yvelinoise lundi
prochain dans le 7-8 sport on continue
ce magazine par du basket trappe
affrontera à domicile caen basket
calvados pour le compte de la 17e
journée du championnat de nationale 3
les deux équipes sont au coude à coude
dans la lutte aux premières places
seulement deux petits points les
séparent au classement les trappistes
son 4e et caen pointe à la 8e place pour
soutenir les saint quentinois le match
se déroule au gymnase paul mallet on
jouera également dans les championnats
de haut en bas c'est le match à ne pas
manquer plaisir deuxième du classement
reçoit le leader saint polois pour le
compte de la 13e journée de nationale 3
défaite interdite pour le premier
plaisir à qui s'est incliné lors de la
dernière journée sur le terrain du 3e à
6 la rencontre se déroulera au gymnase
nicholas leur de plaisir en volleyball
on jouera également dans le championnat
de nationale 3 le club de plaisir villes
pro on reçoit dans son gymnase l'équipe
de caudry un match capital les deux
équipes flirte avec la zone de
relégation et sont séparés que par un
petit pont classement
la rencontre se jouera ce dimanche 4
mars à domicile de 13h 30 ans enfin du
rugby on le disait précédemment dans ce
à 7,8 sport plaisir c'est presque
maintenu dans le championnat de fédérale
2 en s'imposant contre arras un maintien
qui pourrait être officiellement assuré
ce dimanche avec une victoire contre
rennes
seul problème les rennais sont
actuellement leader de ce championnat et
compte 50 points de plus que les
plaisirs ouah c'est la fin de cette
fuite sport merci l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine passé une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]